who could replace boris johnson as tory
leader and the next prime minister here
are the runners and riders
first up we have the foreign secretary
liz truss she's long been touted as a
potential successor to bosch johnson and
we are selling tea to china she's a
favorite of the right of the party often
playing up to comparisons to margaret
thatcher yorkshire tea
and is the longest continuously serving
member of the cabinet having held
positions under david cameron theresa
may and boris johnson
the chancellor may have been a shoe-in a
few months ago
complete with slick social media
graphics he was the hero of the pandemic
introducing measures such as eat out to
help out the furlough scheme and the
stub duty holiday whatever extra
resources our nhs needs to cope with
coronavirus it will get but with
revelations about his billionaire wife's
non-dom status and a number of policies
unpopular with tory mps like increasing
national insurance contributions his
stock has since fallen
through the invasion of ukraine putin
his inner circle in his generals are now
mirroring fascism and tyranny 77 years
ago the defense secretary ben wallace
has seen his popularity rise after his
handling of the ukraine war but he's a
long-term ally of the prime minister and
has said he doesn't want the job he was
even seen accompanying the prime
minister to the confidence boat the
education secretary nadim zahawi could
make a case for the leadership he
oversaw the vaccine roll out as maxine's
minister which earned him the reputation
as a safe pair of hands and he's the
second most popular candidate among tory
membership
and what about the other big names we're
all familiar with jeremy hunt is
currently the chair of the health and
social care committee and came up
against boris johnson in the last
leadership race which johnson won
he hasn't been in government since boris
johnson sacked him as foreign secretary
but that could play to his advantage as
not being tainted by association good
morning mr rob rob also ran last time
and didn't do very well
his odds aren't great and he could be
facing trouble in the next general
election in his constituency of esha
where he has a very slim majority of 2
700.
home secretary pretty patel has long
been popular with the activists and the
right of the tory party with her views
on immigration and public spending but
her star appears to have faded recently
facing criticism for her handling of the
small boat crossings in the channel
should the culture housing and community
secretary michael gove choose to run
again he would be one of the most
experienced candidates but gove has been
at the heart of boris johnson's
government throughout and this close
association could hurt him
and what about the outsiders they
shouldn't be underestimated as we've
seen in the past with jeremy corbyn and
rory stewart tom tukenhart is chairman
of the foreign affairs select committee
and a former soldier who's been very
vocal and critical of the government's
handling of the afghanistan crisis
though lacking in ministerial experience
he could be a favorite for the one
nation tori party wing especially if
jeremy hunt chooses not to stand
penny mordant was defence secretary and
is now an international trade minister
her odds are strong and she's popular
with tory mps and after her lack of
endorsement for the prime minister ahead
of the confidence vote leadership may be
in her sights
the right thing to do